a multi-million dollar car you don't  really want to scratch the paint we  create replicas that cost substantially  less and also meet the performance  requirements and the needs of production  so that they can shoot more easily  around the car we're going to build 15  plus supercars in less than six months  the Koenigsegg Agera Lamborghini Sesto  Elemento Spa no GTA a Saleen s7 McLaren  p1 then a bugatti veyron one of the main  things that the movie is about is a  realism of racing  it's called Need for Speed we need to  have real speed real action  and so we have to be able to meet those  kind of performance demands so that that  level of action is unsurpassed by  anything you've ever seen before  you